hello everyone and welcome to a game
i've been waiting to show for a very
long time
uh as you know the two of them and by
two of them i mean the rashid medinav
and
michelle have played four games
altogether four classical games
in their entire life and we've shown
three of them so far so before you check
out this game if you're new to chess
or maybe just joining the channel uh the
first three links in the description
below will be
uh the three games i've already made a
video on uh regarding uh two of these
gentlemen
so check out uh those three videos first
because before watching this one because
uh well
it's very important and uh i mentioned a
lot about their friendship about
what they did together about how anish
medina helped
misha during his world church
championship match against botvinnik in
1960
so i don't want to repeat myself if you
guys are interested in that
first three links in the description
below do check it out
and also a very special fourth link for
older subscribers i'm sure
you know what it is it is a short
documentary on rasheed
medina by jessica fisher so do check
that out as well
now that being said uh why i saved
this one for last so this is the last
game we'll be showing between these two
gentlemen
unless you know history uncovers more of
them maybe some friendly games or
something like that
but like we said in the previous videos
uh rashid had the white pieces in all
four games against misha
and uh when we're talking about chess
and
attacking chess in particular uh there
is no one
no one greater than than uh the magician
from riga however
uh except in this particular matchup
when he faces a rashid
medinov medinov is the is the attacker
uh as uh well no no one attacks attacks
better than ishmael
even uh the the great attacking style of
the of the pirate of riga pales in
in comparison to uh to uh rasheed
medinov and i know this sounds very
weird to you if you're just
joining us uh here on the channel or in
the chess world in general but
uh it is the way it is and this game is
very special because well i'm just going
to show it to you and then
uh you're going to tell me how how you
enjoyed it so like i said do check out
the previous games if you already
checked them out
let's check out the game so next medinov
opens
with e4 and for those of you who are
interested
a little bit more about this game uh it
was played in 1959 in the ussr
championship in the
in belizi uh so let's check it out uh
features
at the sicilian con variation so e4 c5
uh we have knight to f3 e6 now and the
d4
captures captures and now a6 so the con
variation of the sicilian
uh similar to the najdorf however
there's no uh knight
knight c3 knight of six whoa what
knight c3 knight of six and these pawns
are here so
uh different but similar uh and here we
have
knight to c3 we have queen to c7 the
queen is very
safe now on c7 because the a6 and uh
wow a6 and these six pawns prevent the
knight from harassing the queen
uh and the white goes a3 prevents black
from nicely developing with bishop to b4
uh we have knight to c6 by nish medina
and
uh sorry by and uh bishop to e3 and now
we transpose into the
uh taimano variation of the sicilian we
have knight to f6
and bishop to e2 and this is even by
today's standards uh
as i'm making this video in 2020 uh
considered the absolute main line
but here we have a sort of a deviation
bishop to d6 today bishop to e7 is
almost
uh almost uh guaranteed so bishop
to d6 was played in the game uh and now
comes queen to d2 yeah andish medina
says uh we're either gonna castle
kingside or queenside uh but
there's uh well there's time for
castling
we have bishop to e5 mishnah wants to
trade off
pieces here as uh he he knows who he's
playing against
and f4 uh ninja medina even encourages
this with bishop captures on the four
bishop captures and another katran d
four captures captures
so now anish medina centralizes his
queen and already we have the first
sacrifice of the game
uh dino is offering the f4 pawn
now here you could capture it or you
could ignore it and just castle the
safety and then you know uh
let's see what happens next probably
five uh attacking the night grabbing
more space and so on
however misha not want to back down from
a challenge he says okay
let's see what you got queen captures on
f4 and here you could bring a rook into
the game nicely with tempo
with an attack on the queen however nesh
medina chooses g3
instead and now okay the queen is under
attack
uh what do you do queen back to c7
another option is
h6 but it looks a bit it looks a bit
passive however from h6 you would be
wow uh preventing the the king from from
castling but okay
misha retreats with the queen to c7 and
now
e5 challenging the knight here the
knight has to go somewhere we have
knight to the d5
and here we have another capture
captures on d5
e captures on d5 and now again
uh rashid could choose to capture on d5
and it's not a problem you could capture
then we have queen captures on c2
uh and we could see we could see a very
strong attack here from niz medina with
bishop to c4
threatening wing characters here and
after castle you get
another castles by white and now you
have real
really big problems with uh with this f
pawn for example if queen goes back to
g6
you can simply capture it because uh
whatever you do
let's say you you capture with the
with the queen just queen e4 and you're
gonna you're gonna lose a lot here for
example if d5
blocking this so you don't lose the
queen e captures on v6 alpha song
and whatever happens here you're just
gonna capture it so instead
after rook captures on f7 black would
have to capture with the rook but now
you just add another defender the rook
is pinned
and the black's entire position crumbles
so uh queen captures on d5
is in fact a great move and black would
have to be
very very careful careful here uh as
as you've seen there probably isn't
enough time to grab the pawn and still
survive
maybe with some insane engine play but
for for human
and not so much so just maybe castling
would be safer here
so instead after uh this uh e captures
on d5 by misha
we don't have queen captures but rather
rasheed castle's queen side so
uh still uh still giving up more
material
uh and misha now goes b5 uh he
grabs more space here he wants to play
bishop here rook the c8 and
attack rasheed's king and c1 however
rook h2f1 just putting rooks on open
files this is what uh
whether or she does best and there is
one
uh game where this position has been
reached but four years after this game
uh where
uh just bishop to be sorry where castles
was played uh however here we have
bishop to b7 and it is as of move 17
that this position has never been
repeated again
so as of this point it's a completely
unique game
and here you could do a lot of things
you could uh try
a lot of stuff you could play queen b4
maybe prevent black from castling king
side
but rashid does what rashid does best
and he sacrifices more material
not sacrifice uh uh
actually because the g7 point is is
under attack but
it does uh offer a very very promising
game
and misha can still prevent all of this
he can still just castle to safety and
say okay i don't really care you can
capture on f7
and we're gonna have some traits here
for example characters king captures and
let's say queen h4 going after the pawn
but after the king defense let's say
bishop d3 threatening to capture here h6
and
black defends well so it this would be
uh very much possible for misha to play
something like this however it's a
passive position white of course is
better
and he doesn't like this so after this
daring e6 move and threatening the g7
pawn
misha does uh well the brave thing he
captures on e6 and he says again
let's see what you got so here queen
captures on g7
and now comes rook to f8 and here
uh well something very very special
happens here but we're just gonna we're
just gonna skip that and uh come back to
it later so here i just want to show you
what happens if a castle queen said if
you cast a queen side just root captures
on f7
and black's position is pretty terrible
however
misha played rook to f8 here and now
medina
played bishop to h5 and you can see that
now
castling would be a bit dangerous
because there's a triple attack on the
f7 pawn here however that's
exactly what misha does he castles queen
side and he says
okay you're you're more than welcome to
go after the f7 pawn
however if you capture this i'm gonna
capture and after let's say the queens
are traded off captures captures and
captures
you don't get win anything because i'm
just going to play e5 i get a beautiful
pass pawn here and my d-pawn is nicely
protected twice
uh so you cannot capture it and the
material on the board is equal
with you know good play from both sides
and most likely
we would see a draw because black has
this point white would probably be able
to create a passport on the king side
and uh well anything could happen but it
would be a draw
retreating with bishop to g4 is very
interesting
as it offers a lot of interesting
possibilities but we're gonna
talk about this idea afterwards here it
doesn't work because just
f5 and there's just no no good
continuation here
so instead after misha's queen side
castle we have rook dita e1
and here uh medina has some tricks up
his sleeve but
uh of course misha realizes what they
are and he goes king to b8
and now misha says okay you can just
capture on f7
i didn't really achieve anything here
it's not much uh but if you wait i'm
probably going to put my rook here and
put some put some pressure here so here
we do have rook captures on f7
rook captures and now queen captures and
here bishop back to
c8 saying okay we can trade queens i
have my
uh e6 pawn nicely defended and and we
play this end game
and uh as uh the rashid sees this is
happening he starts
bringing his key into the game as you
know you have to have an active king in
an end game
so misha says okay queen a5 check if you
go any further up the board i'm just
going to capture your rook so here
rashid has to go back and misha also
goes back
queen to c7 uh we have queen to f6
now and uh here comes queen to d6
guarding uh against any weird captures
you might
pile up on this pawn here so queen to d6
now
uh the queen is nicely centralized and
if white doesn't hurry up maybe ideas
like like b4 are coming so here queen to
d4
stopping any pawn pushes and the queen
is just nicely placed here e5
is covered twice this is covered twice
and not a lot for for misha to do here
so he goes rook to f8
uh and now comes rook to e5
just uh grabbing more space here and
bishop to d7
we have bishop back all the way to e2
and now bishop backed the e8 by misha uh
the bishop would be would be very nicely
placed on this diagonal
so here bishop to d3 here
c4 might seem like a good idea because
the queen is undefended
on d6 but it doesn't work because after
captures and captures
you can just play anything here you
don't have to react to this you can play
rook f3
and now it's just a a very weird a weird
position
for for white i mean there's not not all
that much to do bishop to a4
check could be an idea so for example if
you if you push the rook back then you
can go rook to b3 and it's it's a
well it it's a weird position for white
to play
so instead not allowing the positioning
of the bishop here we have bishop to d3
by ninja medina and
king the b7 now misha also starts
bringing the king into the game
uh we have rook to g5 uh hoping to get
some action here
along the along the seventh rank and now
rook to f7 of course misha stops this
queen to e5 now offering a queen trade
and here uh
misha obliges we have captures capture
well uh sorry captures captures and rook
to e7
uh guarding the e6 pawn king d2
and now comes king to c6 with king to e3
and king to d6 now putting pressure on
the rook here
king to d4 and now only now bishop to g6
uh we have a trait of bishops captures
captures and now rook to g5
going after the uh the isolated g pawn
and the white is still hoping to create
a pass pawn here
uh by pushing g4 h4 h5 whereas black
will try and play in the center
so here uh you could go uh rook to g7
however if rook to g7 right away then h4
is very strong because
h5 is coming and well you're not going
to be able to capture here
so there's a different idea e5 with
check
so what do you do here king back to e3
uh anish medina has to step back a
little bit and only now king the g7
and now you've pushed back the white
king and now h4
uh is playable however it is much
different nishmedinov goes for h4 but
now king e6
with h5 and now king the f6 putting
pressure on the rook and now
uh niche medina trades everything rook
captures with rook captures h captures
king captures and
just b3 and this is where the
magic happens here misha plays king to
f5 so you can see that he has a pass
pawn here
rashid has a past jeep on and the
material on the board is completely
equal and
this game is uh completely equal with
perfect play of course
it's a draw and it's very hard to make a
mistake here however
this is exactly where energy medium
makes his mistake
and here like he could play c3 he could
do just waste moves with the king with a
king to f3
but for some reason he played c4 here
and
uh well it was uh it was in this
position that uh
well uh rasheed and niz medina resigned
the game and
well for of course the captures on c4
was played
uh and here medina resigned and this is
the only game
misha won against in medina out of the
four games that they played
which is incredibly interesting because
it's uh hard
to understand what uh he was thinking
when he played c4
probably he thought about the d4 check
then white is winning after king to d3
because he
he will get another pass pawn you cannot
push the pawn because you lose
this pawn uh it's gonna be it's gonna be
i don't know he probably thought of this
maybe he was low on time
uh but this is what misha said after
this uh nez
obtained a completely one position then
blundered
this victory did not give me any
particular pleasure and now you might
think
uh but where is this a completely uh
winning position that uh misha is
talking about we haven't seen such a
thing in this game
but that's exactly why i told you that
we're gonna go back to this
one position one very special position
here after d
captures on e6 and the queen captures
here we had
rook to f8 and now i didn't ask you to
pause the video because i wanted to show
you how the game
uh unrolled and then uh i'm going to ask
you to pause the video now
so pause the video now and win the game
for medina
while i give you a couple of seconds as
this is a true truly a remarkable idea
uh so uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on finding a
move that
uh medina almost played but didn't uh
and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's bishop
to g4
rashid played bishop to h5 but bishop to
g4
is in fact the the move that uh
well makes it impossible for black to
make a move it seems like a silly idea
but for example if you try castling here
then you get just the very unpleasant
bishop captures an e6 check look at this
just
just amazing bishop captures an e6 check
and
you're gonna lose everything here like
there's a triple attack on the f7 pawn
uh you're gonna lose a lot of material
and the white white is winning
and if you actually capture the bishop
then uh then the problem is queen
captures an f8 and this is such a such
an
uh nish medina position that it's
incredible that
rashid didn't find this because now
you're up material and if the queen is
accepted then you get the rook captures
on f8 with
check king to d7 and now rook to f7 with
check king has to move doesn't really
matter you're gonna get capture here
capture here
and now it's five points against five
points but the rook of course will
beat a bishop so bishop to g4
an incredibly strong move prevents black
from castling uh the black king is
forced to remain in the center of the
board but
there is no good defense here like black
could
limp on for for a few more moves but
it's not it's not going to be playable
for example
if you go sorry not that we already
tried that for example rook the c8
you can threaten checkmate of course
black can also go on the counter attack
but just c3
and there is no move you don't have this
you don't have this everything is
covered
the bishop is looking very weird there
because the pawn is on d5
and there just isn't a lot here for
example queen to e7 you still capture on
e6 this is
insane for example here f captures here
rook captures an f8 you have to capture
with the queen and then queen captures
and b7
again leaves black in a position that
you
you don't want to defend the king is
bare bear naked here you know wide open
uh you you you get the rook into the
game and it's just going to be
incredibly difficult for for black to
defend this if
if at all possible so maybe like
maybe an engine with uh you know uh you
know
surgical precision might be able to do
it but in those days uh two
two attackers such as uh nishmedinov and
and misha
they would not play such defensive moves
and you know that the game would end
so after this rook the f8 it's it's
really incredible that
you know medina picked up the bishop and
he went
he went for it but then he just went one
square too far
and uh it didn't happen but maybe maybe
that's uh you know
what had to happen maybe kaiser smiled
on misha that day and she said
you know misha you will not lose to nez
medina
for uh four to zero you will have one
win against him
and you know this is how it happened it
wasn't the spectacular win by misha
uh first uh missed a brilliancy and then
he blundered with that c4 move in a
completely drawn position
so i mean uh it's a shame that bishop to
g4 wasn't played but again
uh okay at least at least one a victory
for misha
and i always mention uh ninja medina who
got the white pieces in all four games
and we know when attacker plays an
attacker that that does uh
tend to matter who who gets uh the white
pieces
uh but like i said uh this game uh
doesn't uh even begin to explain how
crazy
both of their attacking styles are so do
check out learn all you can about rashid
nish medinav
uh do check out the three links in the
description below uh there are the three
games i've already covered
between the two of them as their their
you know all the games are pretty insane
and do check out the documentary on the
rasheed
it's a very short one like 15 minutes
per video there are like three videos so
like 45 minutes
uh you will learn a lot and you will you
know
gain a lot of ass knowledge and you will
maybe uh
start to appreciate the genius behind
the the tatar master uh that is
rashid nishmedinov uh so yeah
uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it we're not gonna be
doing any any special things uh for this
channel reaching
800 000 subscribers uh as you know the
situation in the world is as it is and
we're not
going to be inviting any guests or
having any parties uh but
maybe maybe when the channel reaches one
million you know
uh the situation in the world will
improve and
uh we're gonna be able to you know do
something have a maybe a
a celebration uh invite some people to
have a tournament uh
and something like that uh but yeah i've
been saving this game for a very long
time so i do hope you enjoyed it and uh
that's it we don't have we have we have
no more games between
medina and tal and this is the last one
so
unless they uncover some secret games
which i hope they do
uh that that's it for for now uh so
uh once again uh i do hope you enjoyed
it check out the links in the
description below uh i would like to
thank
edgar rustica uh thomas girl sergio
and from welsh for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out the links in the
description below uh see you soon